this video is sponsored by the problem
solving website and app brilliant
on one morning when sam woke up he found
himself no longer inside his body
through a camera on top of a computer
monitor he looked out at what appeared
to be his own bedroom completely
ordinary and familiar however in the
section where his bed should have been
now stood a large supercomputer which he
appeared somehow to be inside his
consciousness uploaded into some sort of
software he had no memory of knowing
about or agreeing to
this must be a dream sam thought to
himself
what's happened to me
as sam looked around though he quickly
felt that intense restless anxiety he
normally felt while trying to fall back
asleep when he was awake
it felt real
the supercomputer was massive standing
tall and wide taking up a large
king-sized bed amount of space in the
back left corner of his bedroom
almost immediately sam picked up on how
to operate it from the inside he
alternated between looking out at his
bedroom and turning the computer's
camera on and off while the camera was
off he navigated around the computer
trying to make sense of himself and his
current state
the computer had all the same functions
of any other computer he had used before
it had access to the internet and all
the applications one might want or
expect
it had one application that sam had
never seen before though it caught his
attention because it was already open
and running minimized in the lower right
dock it was labeled mind wear and had a
minimalistic brain design as its icon
sam opened it and the window slid up on
the top words read sam underscore gray
underscore v dot prime
the rest of the application window was
filled with various lines of code
jumping around along with what appeared
to be associated graphs visuals of
various waves and color-coded brain maps
in this moment sam realized he was
observing his consciousness
in an unfiltered and unadulterated form
before it ever touched the surface and
sublimated into the world he was
watching the essence of his true self
it terrified him and he quickly
minimized out of the window
then he went over to the social media
applications on the computer where he
spent the rest of the morning
sam was a relatively popular social
media content creator himself he posted
various types of lifestyle vlog videos
on the social media platform known as
essence
he spent some portion of the morning
looking at his own page in his old
videos
then he looked at the pages of others
that produced similar content then he
looked at the pages of some of his
friends both past and present
what a strange career i've chosen sam
thought to himself i've basically been
made by an algorithm who even am i who
even are my friends it's a constant
performance but for what am i trying to
prove myself to the world prove what
that i can be someone i'm not am i
trying to be important somehow important
to what to who what even is important i
don't even know and yet i constantly
push and pull levers and buttons to be
it i tell myself i'm trying to entertain
people and contribute a verse to the
world but the world is composed of
millions of voices all screaming at the
same time about literally everything
saying ultimately nothing that song
doesn't need any more verses
sam quickly realized that he had a
meeting with his manager john that day
scheduled for 2pm it was already 1 45
and he was supposed to meet john at a
cafe several miles away sam thought for
a moment and simply could not bring
himself to deal with such an endeavor
briefly forgetting that he was stuck
inside a computer that could not easily
be relocated anywhere
i'll just call john and tell him i can't
make it sam thought
after calling john on a voice conference
application and explaining the situation
john didn't really understand and
frankly he didn't really care
he was a good social media talent
manager in the sense that he was an
effective one but perhaps by virtue of
this he was also quite insensitive and
abrasive
by the end of the conversation john
decided to go to sam instead after being
led in by one of sam's apartment
managers they briefly spoke about the
originally intended topics of their
meeting and then quickly moved on to the
new issue at hand
just produce content from home sam at
least until you figure everything out
you need to keep the consistent schedule
if you want to keep things going if you
falter you lose adapt for now but don't
sway too far it still has to feel
familiar you know just pretend
everything's alright and make it work
john said before leaving sam alone in
his room again
over the following weeks sam began
trying to produce content from the
confined state of his bedroom inside the
giant nearly unmovable supercomputer
that was now him
he worked his hardest to keep things
going and satisfy his audience his
manager and everyone else affected by
his work and financial stability
the problem samsoon found though was
that filming vlogs or producing content
of this form was rather difficult if
you're inside a computer and could no
longer move or engage with the world in
a meaningful way
at first sam had some of his friends
come over to make content together from
his room they tried coming up with
various ideas that would maintain some
large consistent appeal while also
operating within the limits of what sam
was able to do as a large unmoving
computer
most of sam's audience didn't really
respond well to any of his initial
attempts though they found the change
abrupt and weird and many voiced their
strong disapproval requesting that sam
go back to his old original style
by the sixth week his audience and
viewership had begun declining
significantly simultaneously sam seemed
to be changing more and more himself as
well he was answering questions with
fewer words and speaking with a flatter
cadence that lacked significant spikes
and dips
he seemed to be becoming more and more
like the machine
throughout this time sam's friends
whenever they were over to make content
would also help sam with various
software updates and hardware
replacements on his computer
the software updates were
self-administered but during the reboot
process it was helpful to have at least
one other person present to ensure that
the computer and mindware application
relaunched successfully as more time
passed though and sam state seemingly
got worse and more distant into the
computer most of his friends visited
less and less the content they made
together wasn't usable for their own
pages or channels and sam couldn't
really collaborate on anything else in
return since most of them were lifestyle
vloggers which sam couldn't really
participate in as a computer
additionally sam's other friends outside
of this content creator circle also
found that they no longer really felt
close or shared many interests or
activities with sam and so they also
started visiting less and less
over time more and more people
disappeared from his life
in one attempt at a different video
format sam made a series of kind of
strange abstract animations with
voice-overs and one of them over a
subtle animation he read the
following in this age where constantly
expressing and sharing one's life in
self is made primary it is
simultaneously reduced to a disembodied
objectification of itself filtered and
directed by algorithms both digital and
social i have access to anything at any
time and i can portray and filter any
version of myself in any way but yet i
engage in nothing deeply and have become
nobody
i have avoided the loss of others by
avoiding all authentic connections i've
avoided the loss and rejection of myself
by never being it what is left of me now
i talk about myself for a living and i
consume other people's content
constantly but i don't really know
anyone and no one really knows me
not really anyway
there are so many thoughts so many
aspects of myself that no one will ever
know that i will never share these
aspects of myself that yearn to touch
the world are buried so far down at this
point it's hard to even say what i'm
talking about here i've wanted to be
popular and important for so long i've
wanted so badly to never be forgotten
that i gave up the self that i wanted to
be liked for
i've become who i wanted to be and i
don't know who he is
this and the other couple similarly
formatted video sam made were poorly
received most of his audience found them
depressing pretentious and or too
self-pitying they wanted to be
entertained and have fun
sam just couldn't help himself from
being caught between the desire to
successfully maintain his career and be
liked while also no longer having any
ability or interest in making content in
the way he did before that did this
thus he never quite said what he wanted
to say or create what he wanted to
create and remain stuck in between a
strange mix of timid authenticity and
churning out content that appeased the
fleeting masses
throughout this period sam's manager
somewhat frequently visited to discuss
strategies for re-evaluating sam's
content and brand
john would also monitor sam's software
updates and hardware issues during his
visits if time allowed as more time went
on sam only got more and more mechanical
in his personality and the style of his
content
ultimately he was unable to ever really
recreate any significant success
soon john stopped visiting as well and
he essentially stopped focusing on him
as a client
sam still remained in loose contact with
two or so close friends but with sam's
increasing mechanical like apathy he
didn't bother to ask them to visit much
nor did they go out of their way to do
so and so they mostly just spoke through
various social medias on birthdays and
other special occasions that reminded
them of each other
otherwise though sam remained mostly
isolated in his room in his computer
working
trying to be liked trying to be popular
trying to find success again
sam's mother gretchen never stopped
visiting sam she would be the one that
always helped him with any software
updates reboots hardware issues etc when
no one else would
sam's father passed when he was younger
and sam was mostly estranged from his
only brother and so his mother was
really the only close family he had
on one of the days gretchen was visiting
while they were talking about work
getting older and sam's father gretchen
said to sam
son i can never truly know what you're
going through what your thoughts sound
like what your emotions feel like what
it feels like to be you but believe me
when i say this
i understand
when i leave here you'll be alone in
this room and alone in your mind but so
will i
so will everyone you don't need to go it
alone any more than that though people
will come and go throughout life
eventually you will say goodbye to your
last friend your last girlfriend or wife
your last parent and finally your last
self
but don't let this knowledge don't let
all the appeals and distractions from
authentic connection with yourself and
with others keep you from trying
from loving from reaching out into the
world and trying to hold on to the
people and things that are real hold on
to what you really care about and say
what you really mean even if no one ever
truly hears you and even if at some
point you have to let go
[Music]
sam continued making and releasing
content for a while although it really
only got stranger the further along he
got in the metamorphosis into the
machine
a couple years later his mother passed
away of an unexpected stroke at age 67.
eventually sam reached a point where he
seemed to become more machine than human
he stopped administering any software
updates either forgetting or not feeling
the emotional impulse to do so this
began to cause problems and the computer
started to have frequent glitches and
system errors which affected the
application that his consciousness was
running on
not long after these errors started
occurring one day the computer crashed
it ran a system reboot and software
update on its own
however when it turned back on the
mindware application crashed while
reopening
it required a manual relaunch
several months later his apartment's
property manager came in and found the
computer along with the rest of sam's
items
within a few days most of the computer
was trashed and the valuable parts were
extracted and sold
[Music]
thank you so much for watching this
video was sponsored by brilliant
in a world that really is now made and
ran by computers it's beneficial for
anyone of any background to actually
have an understanding of various aspects
of computer science including the
fundamentals of algorithms search
engines data structures and the nature
of artificial networks you can learn all
this and much more on the interactive
problem solving website and app
brilliant for example if you've ever
been interested in knowing how computer
programming and algorithms actually work
how programs and systems run on these
series of instructions and transform
facts about the world into information
but were put off by the obscurity of
coding language in brilliant course
algorithm fundamentals you can learn
about this and more without having to
sift through the weeds of coding syntax
using interactive challenges you can
shift around blocks of pseudo code and
get immediate feedback on your results
making it understandable and immersive
and allowing the coding syntax to be a
lot less intimidating brilliant also has
60 plus other excellent courses in a
variety of other math and science
related subjects including anything from
fun logical brain teasers to finance
statistics and cryptocurrency to
advanced mathematics and classical
physics and beyond for many learning
these sorts of subjects can often be
hard to start or find very engaging on
your own but by utilizing newly enhanced
digital interactives puzzles and
storytelling brilliant makes the
learning process fun rewarding and
effective
if you're interested in joining
brilliant you can go to brilliant.org
pursuit of wonder or click the link in
the description below to sign up for a
free trial the first 200 people will
also get 20 off their annual premium
membership
and of course as always again thank you
for watching and see you next video
[Music]
you